[Music]
the only way i know how to say that is
they told me it's millennium take off
the m that's how i remember it
in today's aid on your side you may not
even realize that certain phrases or
words you use in emails or
correspondence at work
may not be appropriate and that's the
reason behind a tool called writer
created by may habib
we communicate is just really always
changing but the language we use at work
shapes the culture very profoundly so
you know good words equals good culture
writer is a chrome extension you can
have right at your cursor
it alerts you while you're typing of any
offensive language
the past year and a half with social
movements coveted and folks moving to
remote remote work that is
it's all really accelerated her business
which only started in 2020.
major companies are using the tool to
analyze and correct their language to
make sure it's free of bias intended or
otherwise
and anybody can use it to help correct
language that is passive aggressive or
just simply negative
here are some key phrases she says you
should avoid
it's kind of scary how quickly passive
aggressive things can
fly off our fingertips so you know if
you write something like
that's your job or um what exactly is
the problem
or as i said before you know all of
these like
very subtly not nice things to say at
work
um we will remind you of you know
and give you corrections for suggestions
for more polite language
and i did ask her for a few other
examples that get flagged by writer
quite regularly she says the word
elderly
she says it has harmful aegis
connotations she says use older person
or senior adult instead
the word exotic she says this has racist
undertones stay away from that one
and man hour she says avoid that one as
there aren't just men
working christian